hello and welcome to this via playing
shake her off that's an i am and he goes
father loves an opening no name okay
yeah this is mrs. Sam Plex principled
reply I think he fought as an
interesting idea it's a bit of a
strange-looking move but I think it's a
good one gaining space yeah yeah a six
it's good gaining the bishop out and
like it's already completely sure that
the position will open up okay do you
three to d4 is a playable move for a
while but it doesn't look very tempting
i would say okay Bishop f5 maybe this is
a certainly possible all right let's do
it putting pressure on d3 again d for
looks wrong killing his own bishop yeah
that it should be rather nice for me I
would assume it's just night XO I can
also castle first so that a difference
probably whoops probably not much
um castling long 92 I don't have bishop
well be sure before doesn't make a lot
of sense okay I just go back yeah so if
I castle alone now well this is probably
on the agenda anyway so let's do it he
doesn't have kini too which is nice as
c2 is hanging and he definitely would
like it only to not on c1 or sum square
so I'm kind of mad not really I was
thinking hmm so Bishop c5 Bishop c5 one
Bishop e3 is actually also interesting
but he might be able to take at him that
that really is possible hmm Bishop c5
I'll go for this I think this is
interesting rook t7 Bishop g7 rock d8
bishops III this looks very very
dangerous for him I don't think Bishop
g7 he can do Oh interesting but ok now I
can just drop back
slinking night be three here hmm ok
let's cover that point I mean maybe he
will really take it at some point I want
to play c5 here anyway to open up and I
double my pawns ok c5 yeah why not it's
the bishop pair it wants to open up and
I have root d6 b6 stuff like that his
king is not really secure here and also
control the only open file which is
really nice so here I can check on b6
I can see one not sure ever have
something great then night might hop
into d5 ok I think I'll go back in this
is probably helpful anyway after he has
gone at 3e for hmm ok if I check now
what's the deal I can also take here
first group d 6 Jack let's check first
King see one Bishop a three what ok come
on that didn't work quite resigned you
know i mean i was a bit better anyway
but it was much easier than I thought
okay so um important point is the
opening I think this line with efore is
an excellent choice for black he gets a
very nice play without any effort yeah
III this is a nice position I have the
bishop and the position is is going to
be opened up as we have seen in the game
check this is just just nice for black
long yeah I'd hear from here you can
certainly think about alternatives the
engine wants to go here also very
logical and then f5 past everything open
that's definitely interesting yeah this
was I was thinking that he cannot take
not sure about it but I thought he
cannot take a third group d 8 bishops
III and then I was thinking b5 could be
even an option trying before like before
I go back and here I thought
compensation with a 55-foot I wasn't
completely sure about this but he played
before yeah now f6 maybe not necessary
with
this is nice now in a position is opened
up and I have some ideas even against
the king yeah then bishop didn't do much
anymore this one and the engine just
wants to take and play the ending yeah I
should I understand but that's not bad i
think lk has to go to a one of course
and then i was considering to take night
and then continue from here not about
not sure maybe this one and then push
the pawn or threaten this one and black
it's better it's two bishops the
position is open and there are some
non-symmetrical aspects in the pawn
structure which always helps the bishops
and this just blundering everything okay
well guys thanks for watching